[Music]
you're a terrible influence you need me
ow yes are you crazy you tell me
so what happened well apparently there
was some name calling and shoving on the
playground by the time a teacher
separated them luke was sitting on
manny's chest luke that's not like you
wait a minute you're luke's father
grandfather so manny's father is
javier can i see guy
that's where he gets his inspired okay
you're he's our son and my grandson i'm
his daughter
so you're his uncle
stop saying that or sit on your chest
again oh wait a second is that what this
was all about he was calling me his
nephew you are my nephew shut up okay
okay
don't you want to keep our room neat you
know in case we entertain who would we
entertain i noticed some lovely tweens
down by the kids club maybe we can find
a nice bun near them by the pool and
send over a couple of virgin mai tais
they may be interested in two
sophisticated men like us
i am a bathroom martian
beep boop boop i am from the nebula of
the great toilet
beep boop bop
i'm curious is there any sand left on
the beach or did you bring it all up to
our bathroom
sorry mom
and now you're sitting on my linen
jacket
yes i can't have nice things oh i'm
sorry i didn't know it was there it's
okay oh oh
stop i'm wearing that tonight i'm
wrinkling you're living i'm wrinkling
your linen oh you know what out i want
you out this isn't working i don't care
where you go as long as you don't stay
here what are you saying what don't you
understand about out fine i'll just move
in with my sisters
oh no who will peel over the bathroom
floor i was brushing my teeth at the
same time
you try to do that
how lucky is reuben so lucky you know
what i say we take this thing out and
see how she flies i don't know my mom
got it for reuben oh so now he won't
even share his toys he never does screw
that guy yeah
you're a terrible influence you need me
so you want to try it
i don't know i'm still feeling guilty
it's reuben's helicopter ruben is the
whole reason we should be doing this
he's barely living proof that life can
change in a second you gotta grab what
you can
when you can
what does this hold you have on me
oh well what do you mean oh well my mom
was gonna kill us us you were flying it
i was in the attic packing boxes you're
gonna help me find it or the next search
will be for you
i like this guy where's he been for
someone who says he likes girls so much
he sure is afraid of them it's a dance
luke chicken dance i can't unlearn how
to treat a lady where does that leave me
waiting till i'm 40 when she looks me up
on facebook after i failed first
marriage okay
what are you doing i'm sick of hearing
you whining about miranda it's time to
make her notice you but we can't we got
a full tank of gas and she's right down
the block now buckle up are you crazy
you tell me
[Applause]
[Music]
okay your turn
uh no way do you want to get your
attention or not
that was amazing did you see the look of
miranda's face no
but you did good thomas please stop
calling me that i hate that movie what
movie
uh oh dead end we gotta make yui i don't
know how to do that
[Music]
she's not here we have the wrong bar
mitzvah now if you like prime rib bubby
you said to blend i picked up some
expressions at the lattice station yes
they're hash browns we're not blending
she's at one of the other two come on
oh sorry such a hurry this one
come on
how could she not be here either this is
hopeless
have a little faith did the jews give up
when the egyptians chased them to the
banks of the red sea how do you know all
this stuff was i the only one listening
to uncle menachem's toast
all right ready nice and easy
you haven't even thrown it yet then it's
your fault i'm doing my part forget it
we need to do something
different let's change your stance try
leaning in
further
now close your eyes
ow ah perfect you think you can do that
every time what get hit on purpose if
you want to get on base and be a hero
some men are born into greatness others
haven't chucked at their face
ah yes
i was thinking maybe just hang out on
bondi beach that's a great idea manny
bondi beach is topless thank you trip
advisor
so uh luke and i are gonna take a break
from the sun yeah we're kind of tired
tired of not seeing boobs
what is this not one topless woman calm
down you're gonna spook the boobs oh
wait two o'clock
oh
hey luke
how deep is that be cool we don't want
to look like idiots
i lost my bathing suit manny help me
find it
i don't have my nose plug little boy are
you okay oh
minnie see something
miss missy he lost this bathing suit oh
honey i can help you find it it's okay
i'm fine oh the water's really clear
uh
hey so you're like the minister kinda
when they lost sal the situation was a
no-brainer which made him think of me
isn't there a lot you have to remember
to marry people not really they all
follow the same basic pattern we're
gathered here today to join these two in
holy matrimony do you take him to be
your lawfully wedded spouse and the
first person says i do right then i
asked the second person do you take him
to be your lawfully wedded spouse you
know the drill right i do then i say by
the powers vested to me by the state of
california i now pronounce you legally
wed bingo bango bongo you're married
awesome
really awesome
oh i can't this is too cold it's either
cold for five minutes or cold forever
oh come on
funny
i always thought i'd be found dead in a
bird suit at the bottom of the grand
canyon you still will buddy
if i ever catch you drinking again your
whole school is going to see this
picture
she she tricked us
i know
as soon as we kill this worm we're gonna
give back
there's no worm
sure throwing a party was a risk but two
hot exchange students just started at
our school best part is they don't
understand just how uncool we are
yet
so we were walking down the hallway when
we stopped by the loft oh
pizza day
um
that's our personal trainer he hates it
when we eat carbs we are two individuals
with our own unique personalities and
ideas
what he said
i won it was the lowest voter turnout in
school history they hated the both of us
but you more
uh
oh hi there i'm luke dunphy student body
president and i'm this isn't about us we
have a classmate who's in a pretty bad
spot
but it doesn't have to end that way with
your help we can save him from getting
beaten up but by his disease a disease
no kids should have to wrestle with
we just need to raise eight thousand
dollars 49 000 to get him that super
deluxe treatment we only need eight
thousand i'm luke dunphy and i approve
this message
hope you have fun here while i'm
shoveling poo in some underground poo
shoveling place well why'd you even come
here if you're so sure you can't get in
i don't know maybe because this is the
one place we might both get in that
might make this whole thing a little
less scary well that's the only reason i
applied two then why are we fighting i
don't know so are we still going to
party yeah i'll put on a hat
what kind of gym bag is that anyway it's
a satchel you ignorant sneeze
you have been so unpleasant lately
how old is this x 44
it's on
oh there you are
wait
your backs
yep and i'm eager to learn a warning my
form's clumsy but i'm great on my feet
i know people tend to get mushy in
moments like this but
with you headed around the world and me
headed off to college
we'll stay close
how come you never wrote a poem for me
don't you get it
they were all for you
[Music]
you